but they're now turning to the southern
border you know a federal judge in
louisiana while he's been weighing a
legal challenge to stop the white house
from ending title 42. you know those are
border restrictions there more than 20
states are supporting the lawsuit to
keep title 42 that rule as you may know
let's border agents send asylum seekers
back to mexico
because of the covet pademic you're
looking live there to eagle pass texas
and that is where our bill delusion is
he's been at the border with the very
latest on the newest crossings
hey bill yeah eric good afternoon to you
eric i can tell you those illegal
crossings are absolutely non-stop here
in eagle pass and that's with title 42
still in place and we'll show you some
of that been a busy day out here take a
look at this drone video we shot here in
eagle pass earlier this morning when we
had another massive single group of well
over 100 illegal immigrants crossing
into eagle pass here this was the fourth
day in a row that we have seen this
these big groups of more than 100 every
day for the last four days around 11
o'clock in the morning here we'll see
these big groups crossing like clockwork
today we saw a cartel scout on the other
side taking a peek at the river before
that group came across 30 minutes later
but certainly this wasn't the only group
we talk about how we see it every day
take a look at this video we saw this
big group of about 150 illegal
immigrants crossing on friday again same
exact thing same loca same location same
time in the morning most of these
migrants crossing here have been from
colombia venezuela and cuba and border
patrol actually reported that just in
the last week they've had more than
eight of these single massive groups
crossing here in eagle pass it's putting
a huge strain on border patrol's
resources they don't have the manpower
to process all these groups so they got
to call in agents from elsewhere and you
hear me say it like a broken record but
it's an important point that just leaves
gaps elsewhere along the border where
cartels can push drugs and runners
through the mayor pro tem of eagle pass
a democrat not happy about what's going
on she wants title 42 to stay in place
and she says it's just causing too many
issues for their city take a listen
as a council person we get phone calls
as in what are y'all going to do about
all these people that are walking the
streets and what are you going to do
about people that are staying here and
that has to be under control we don't do
that we do
local business this is federal
and eric late this afternoon we just
learned of an unprecedented deal that
was reached between the state of texas
and the mexican state of cuahuilla last
night that's the state directly across
from us here in eagle pass what we're
being told is that the state of texas is
going to start providing razor wire to
mexican authorities so they can beef up
border security on their side of the
border i'm told the mexicans are going
to be coming here to eagle pass in the
coming days the texas national guard is
going to train them on how to deploy the
razor wire then they will take
possession of the wire go back into
mexico and start constructing it along
their border i'm told this is the first
time something like this has happened
we'll send it back to you how about that
all right bill thanks so much an eagle
pass hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else